[Applause]
what's the message of radical trans
Liberation now what does it mean I'm not
here to talk to you st no no one radical
trans Liberation
now I do not believe that biological
males should be allowed to compete in
women's sports my point of contention
with what you just said there would be
that biological males are dominating
biological females I have not seen that
play out you know there are over 80
examples of women who either lost out on
opportunities or scholar ships you have
Mary Gregory I believe in powerlifting
you have women cycling a record that was
set you have examples across the board
in weightlifting in cycling in swimming
in track not to mention Combat Sports
where women can actually be physically
harmed so yeah it has happened quite a
bit